[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de cette
semaine voici les titres de ce vendredi
30 mars
assurance chômage formation
professionnelle apprentissage les
projets de réformes sociales
s'enchaînent pour le gouvernement la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
étaient présentes jeudi soir à vélizy
pour un atelier citoyens et répondre aux
questions des habitants
le président de la république a annoncé
l'école obligatoire dès l'âge de 3 ans
cette semaine lors des assises de la
maternelle est ce suffisant pour réduire
les inégalités sociales des plus petits
si la place de l'école est sacralisé
qu'elle doit être celle des parents nous
poserons notamment ces questions à notre
invité noemi de saint sernin coach en
développement personnel
auteur et formatrice spécialisée dans
l'accompagnement des parents dans le
reste de l'actualité nous reviendrons
sur les multiples hommages rendus cette
semaine au colonel arnaud beltrame dans
les yvelines est victime du terrorisme
il ya une semaine ou encore l'événement
en piste pour l'emploi organisé jeudi au
vélodrome de saint quentin en yvelines
il est arrivé en tête du premier tour
avec près de 48% des voix jacques
chesnais élu d'opposition à marly le roi
devrait devenir le premier secrétaire
départemental du parti socialiste un
second tour est prévu ce week end
mais jean claude husson maire de saint
arnoult en yvelines a retiré sa
candidature avec 37% des suffrages
jacques chesnais est donc seul en lice
pour succéder à sandrine grand gang à la
tête du ps local 252 militants seulement
yvelinois ont pris part au vote
en politique également le député de la
république en marge de la 2ème
circonscription des yvelines jean noël
barrot a organisé jeudi 29 mars à vélizy
un nouvel atelier citoyen invité de
marque pour cette rencontre entre élus
et citoyens la ministre du travail mme
muriel pénicaud à la présenter
mesure de ses prochaines réformes
sociales sur l'apprentissage l'assurance
chômage ou encore la formation
professionnelle reportage de nicolas
d'andré assurance chômage formation
professionnelle apprentissage le
programme de l'atelier citoyen organisé
par le député yves binois jean-noël
barrot avec comme invité de marque la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
le but c'est effectivement d'avoir un
dialogue c'est à dire que la ministre va
nous expliquer le contenu de ce projet
de loi puisque il n'est pas encore tout
à fait connu enfin il vient d'être
reconnu et puis ces deux d'avoir les
réactions des uns et des autres pour
pouvoir effectivement le moment venu
l'enrichir lors du débat parlementaire
s'engager pour la liberté de choisir son
avenir professionnel c'est le nom de ce
projet de loi préparé par la ministre
plusieurs mesures prévues dans ce texte
notamment garantir l'assurance chômage
pour les démissionnaires et les
travailleurs indépendants sous certaines
conditions ou encore simplifier l'accès
à des formations professionnelles
conçoit salariés qu'on soit demandeur
d'emploi on veut pouvoir choisir sa voie
professionnelle et pas simplement subir
des changements c'est la meilleure
protection contre le chômage c'est la
formation professionnelle c'est pour ça
qu'on veut investir à fond sur ce sujet
autres points évoqués dans les
discussions l'apprentissage plusieurs
modifications envisagées notamment
donner la possibilité aux entreprises ou
à une branche professionnelle de créer
son propre centre de formation des
apprentis
je pense que l'apprentissage aujourd'hui
c'est la voie royale pour réussir et
notamment pour intégrer nos futurs
apprenants qui effectivement peuvent
envisager par la suite une poursuite
d'études professionnelles dans ce cas
dit la ministre ce soir c'est du grand
flou c'est beaucoup de 10 des déjà
entendu on va faire mieux avec moins
pour plus le problème c'est que on nous
parle de simplification est aujourd'hui
le système de financement peut paraître
complexe pour les gens qui ne
connaissent rien mais en fait ils
fonctionnent très bien
ce texte de loi doit être transmis pour
avis au conseil d'état il devrait être
présenté au parlement au début du mois
de mai et la ministre du travail est
resté dans les yvelines vendredi matin
elle s'est rendue dans un espace de
coworking à mes v et à rencontrer sur
place des salariés et chefs d'entreprise
indépendants qui ont recours au
télétravail
selon des données du ministère du
travail 61% des français aimeraient
pratiquer justement le télétravail mais
seulement 17 % l'utilisent actuellement
le gouvernement qui est critiqué en ce
moment par les avocats et les magistrats
une journée morte dans la justice était
organisée ce vendredi un peu partout en
france et notamment à versailles au
tribunal de grande instance à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats avocats juges et
greffiers s'opposent au projet de loi de
réforme de la justice qui sera présenté
mi avril en conseil des ministres les
manifestants dénoncent une nouvelle
organisation judiciaire et lisible
éloigné du citoyen propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude dans ce
projet nous constatons qu'il ya une
forme de privatisation de certains pans
de la justice
aucune aucun texte de façon à rassurer
et à permettre aux fonctionnaires de
savoir qu'est ce qu'il en sera pour eux
demain en matière d'organisation des
tribunaux et surtout de grandes
modifications pour le justiciable
parce que contrairement à ce que dit la
ministre ce n'est pas pour rapprocher le
citoyen mais pour une partie de la
population l'éloigner de la justice
encore et toujours des réformes dans
l'actualité après celle de l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur celle du bac ou
encore le cpa 12 le gouvernement se
penche maintenant sur les maternelles
mardi et mercredi était organisé des
assises avec 400 professionnels du monde
éducatif et de la petite enfance le
grand public à a retenu lui l'annoncé de
l'abaissement de l'école obligatoire à 3
ans à partir de la rentrée 2010 9 97 %
des enfants sont déjà à l'école à cet
âge alors est-ce une
avancée fondamentale utile pour les
enfants nous allons poser la question à
notre invité tout de suite nos amis de
saint sernin bonsoir ça vous êtes
spécialisé dans l'accompagnement des
parents pour l'éducation des enfants
notamment auteur coach en développement
personnel votre avis déjà en tant que
spécialiste est ce que c'est une bonne
idée de rendre obligatoire l'âge l'école
l'entrée à l'école à trois ans alors que
c'est déjà le cas un rapport beaucoup
ben oui déjà plus de 97% donc très peu
de gens sont concernés par ça finalement
moi je reviens juste envie de dire mais
quelles vont être les moyens donc
aujourd'hui a pas tellement de retours
sur ces assises
je sais qu'il ya eu des
neuroscientifiques qui ont été
interrogés donc est-ce qu'il va y avoir
des moyens ce qui va y avoir un projet
différent pour justement accompagner les
maternelles aujourd'hui la problématique
principale pour les maternelles
justement c'est l'accompagnement qui
soit bien suivi que ce ne soit pas on va
dire la garderie parfois certains
critiquent la maternelle en disant que
c'est une grande garderie
moi je crois que c'est surtout les
parents qui l'utilisent comme une
garderie mais je crois pas que les
enseignants seraient contents qu'on dit
qu'on dise que c'est une garderie
j'accompagne des parents mais
j'accompagne aussi des professionnels de
la petite enfance 1 beaucoup
d'enseignants et leurs problèmes
principaux c'est surtout le manque de
moyens et amont à mon niveau à moi ce ne
sont pas des moyens pédagogiques mais
plutôt des moyens des moyens
psychologiques c'est à dire qui et les
problèmes des enseignants c'est pas de
pas savoir faire avec les enfants il ya
sûrement peut-être un peu de moyens
pédagogiques mais c'est aussi comment je
fais face aux émotions de ses enfants
comment je fais quand j'ai des enfants
dont les parents divorcent et c est donc
qu ils ne sont pas toujours formés à ça
et pour ça il n'aurait pas raison
peut-être plus de personnes en classe
pour pouvoir suivre plus précisément
certains d'entre eux que d'autres je
pense pas que c'est une histoire de
nombre de personnes mais plutôt de
formation des enseignants et de leur
système puisqu'ils sont complémentaires
et donc ce serait donner des moyens à ce
niveau là et aussi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec ce que nous
apprennent les neurosciences sur la
façon dont fonctionne le cerveau et
notamment le cerveau des enfants
je pense surtout aux travaux
de céline alvarez qui qui démontre à
travers une expérience réelle dans des
classes de maternelle dans une classe de
maternelle ou à regrouper les trois
niveaux et on lui a donné à ce moment là
effectivement des moyens pédagogiques
on a pu mesurer des résultats absolument
fantastique alors à travers cette
semaine dédiée ou plutôt ces deux jours
dédiés à la maternelle le gouvernement
place l'école en première ligne pour
lutter contre le déterminisme social
c'est le mot employé contre les
inégalités aussi entre des enfants qui
jouissent d'un bagage culturel plus
importants que d'autres
est ce que c'est à la maternelle que
tout se joue selon vous alors c'est un
peu restreint comme façon de voir les
choses que plus tard aussi des
inégalités peuvent se creuser ou alors
que d3 en d2 en peut être il faut tout
de suite combler ces inégalités comme le
dit le gouvernement
alors moi ce que je dirais c'est que
tout se joue dans l'enfance ça c'est sûr
et l'entente vous ciblez entre quel âge
à quel âge j'ai envie de dire même
peut-être même avant la conception à la
conception du bébé pendant la période
terrine intra utérine et même après
c'est à dire qu'on estime que les
blessures en tout cas les traumatismes
toutes ces choses là sont formés et
surtout le conditionnement de l'enfant
est fait à partir du moment où il
termine son adolescence donc jusqu'à
14-15 ans et il faut il faut il faut
cibler du coup vous n'êtes pas vous êtes
vous en réalité ou pour des assises de
l'enfance si je puis me permettre
ben oui moi j'aurais été pour la réforme
du système éducatif dans sa globalité et
parce que si on met des moyens au niveau
de la maternelle alors comment on les
suit après en primaire et comment les
accompagne au delà au collège et et
ainsi de suite
voilà alors pour revenir sur sur les
maternelles et plus sur votre votre
vision aussi des enseignants vous vous
dites vous personnellement que plus que
répondre aux besoins de l'enfant
il est intéressant de replacer la focale
au niveau de l'enseignement ou du parent
le parent ou en parler dans quelques
instants
mais le focal sur l'enseignant qu'est ce
que vous entendez par là qu'elle est ce
que c'est alors vous disiez c'est pas le
nombre pour vous qui est important pour
ré insisté là dessus qu'est ce qui est
important pour l'enseignant qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour améliorer leurs
conditions de travail par exemple alors
au niveau des conditions de travail d'un
enseignant je les connais pas donc c'est
pas là dessus où je vais pouvoir être
d'une grande aide
en revanche je connais ce que les
enseignants rencontre comme
problématique par exemple de gérer leurs
propres émotions face aux émotions des
enfants de savoir accompagner un enfant
qui est en difficulté mais plutôt
psychologique de savoir comment ça
fonctionne le cerveau d'un enfant est
pourquoi il ya certaines choses qui ne
fonctionnent pas dans la classe ou
pourquoi ça fonctionne que pour un
certain nombre d'enfants
aujourd'hui on a tendance à catégoriser
les enfants ya les bons et les moins
bons
il ya ceux qui sont doués pour telle
chose et d'autres qui ne sont pas doués
pour telle chose moi je crois que tous
les enfants ont des talents et que
l'école peut révéler ses talents sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ils ne s'intéressent qu'à
une certaine catégorie talençais en
france on valorise valorise par exemple
les sciences plus que toute autre
discipline
mais qu'en est il de la musicalité de
l'empathie de plein de tous les sujets
qui ont été évoqués dans les assises de
la laddh et maternelles de la maternelle
une réflexion aussi sur vous dites vous
que les parents les enseignants
transmettent aussi leur peur aux enfants
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
est-ce que c'est là aussi une forme
d'inégalité peut-être des enseignants ou
des atsem les personnes qui s'occupent
aussi des maternelles à l'école qui sont
peut-être bien équilibrée
psychologiquement sont peut-être plus
intéressant pour former les enfants que
ceux qui ont des problèmes antérieurs à
leur vie passée c'est ce que vous dites
alors on a tous des problèmes s'il
devait régler deux problèmes on a tous
eu des choses dans notre passé qui qui
nous ont peut-être bliss et maintenant
quand on devient adulte
on arrive avec un conditionnement
justement fruits de ce passé et donc moi
ce que je dis ce que j'ai appelé cette
fameuse doctrine de parentalité ou
d'éducation responsable c'est que le
problème n'est plus chez l'enfant mais
plutôt dans le regard que l'on porte sur
lui dans l'attitude que nous mêmes nous
allons avoir vis-à-vis de lui et tout à
coup ça induit beaucoup de ce qu'on peut
obtenir de l'enfant moi je pense que
tous les enfants ont des capacités
formidable qu'ils sont bienveillants
naturellement les neurosciences le
prouve aujourd'hui et que c'est le
regard que le parent ou que l'enseignant
va porter sur l'enfant qui va
conditionner ce qu'il va être ou croire
être encore par exemple les adultes
agité bon
vont faire des enfants agités c'est ce
que vous entendez par exemple à lorsque
alors j'ai pris un exemple oui vous avez
pris un mach 6 je vais vous donner un
exemple concret c'est que on va
interpréter le comportement de l'enfant
est déposé sur lui une étiquette
hyperactif
mais est-ce que cet enfant hyperactif ou
c'est juste un grand sportif qui a
besoin de bouger d'explorer le monde qui
l'entourent est ce que l'enfant fait
vraiment exprès de d'attirer l'attention
qu'est ce qu'il a à nous dire pourquoi
il attire l'attention comme ça pourquoi
il se comporte de cette manière alors il
y à ce qui se passe dans sa propre
famille et à lui et puis il y a aussi le
regard parfois que l'enseignant porte
sur lui ou l'attitude que l'as
l'enseignant a avec lui et dont
l'enseignant ne se rendent parfois pas
compte parce qu'il est et en plus s'il
n'est pas formé à ça ça devient
compliqué pour lui une dernière question
est ce qu'avec ces assises de la
maternelle on comprend que le
gouvernement souhaite remplacer l'école
en première ligne du cou pour
l'éducation des enfants est ce que du
coup vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée
là que où cette impression là qui se
dégage que que l'école est le premier
lieu de l'éducation pour un enfant
devant peut-être à la famille ou les
parents est ce que l'école à ce rôle la
principale non moi je dirais que la
famille quand même c'est primordial
on sait qu'un enfant ça ça apprend par
modélisation et savent à modéliser
l'enseignant on l'entend quand on a eu
des enfants on voit bien qu'ils jouent à
la maîtresse on voit bien les
expressions qu'ils utilisent on sait
bien ce que dit la maîtresse ou la
mettre à l'abri jouer à ce jeu la
bagarre oui d'ailleurs et les enfants
apprennent par imitation donc déjà quand
on est enseignant aux parents c'est
important d'être le bon modèle si on
veut des enfants respectueux il suffit
d'être si on veut des enfants qui se
tiennent bien à table il suffit soit
même se tenir bien à table
ansari être peint ce tableau on peut se
dire droit relais droit par exemple en
france tiendra plus droit aussi en tout
cas ça agit par imitation et je pense
que les parents sont quand même les
référents des enfants leur modèle aussi
maintenant l'école derrière c'est très
important parce qu'on y passe du temps
et si elle devient est obligatoire pour
tout le monde mais les enfants vont
passer beaucoup de temps très tôt pour
certains même ça commence dès la crèche
donc c'est important d'avoir les bons
dell aussi à l'école merci noémie de
saint sernin d'avoir répondu à toutes
vos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialisé dans l'accompagnement des
parents pour l'éducation des enfants
auteurs coach en développement personnel
hauteur on voit d'ailleurs l'un de vos
livres
les clés du passé ici en plateau merci
beaucoup et bon ils tiennent à vous une
avancée majeure pour notre histoire
grâce à des chercheurs de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
à présent une équipe menée par le
docteur philippe charlier a pu
reconstituer le visage de l'homme de cro
magnon
comme vous allez le voir voilà justement
à l'écran un visage marqué par la
présence de nombreux modules due à une
maladie génétique sur le visage ces
recherches ont été réalisées dans le
cadre du 150e anniversaire de la
découverte d'un squelette d'un individu
mâle homo sapiens datant de 28000 en
environ on passe maintenant à
l'actualité de la semaine
l'actualité de cette semaine marque et
bien sûr par l'hommage national rendu
toute cette semaine au colonel arnaud
beltrame cérémonie aux invalides à paris
mercredi mais aussi dans les yvelines
la ville de montigny le bretonneux a
observé une minute de silence dans la
salle du conseil municipal plus d'une
cinquantaine de personnes étaient
présentes pour se souvenir du gendarme
décédé il ya une semaine après avoir
pris la place d'une otage dans le super
u de trèbes dans une attaque terroriste
le gendarme avait succombé ensuite à ses
blessures dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi il ya une semaine un sacrifice
dont il faut se rappeler pour le maire
de montigny le bretonneux on l'écouté je
pense que la démarche que ce colonel a
fait en sacrifiant sa vie pour sauver
celle de quelqu'un d'autre est tout à
fait exceptionnel dans l'histoire de
france et un moment donné nous en tant
qu'élu mais également tous les
représentants de la population de
montigny nous avons souhaité faire cet
hommage
non seulement c'est important mais c'est
même indispensable cette barbarie de
l'islamisme c'est en étant tous unis
tous vraiment solidaires qu'on arrivera
je ne dis pas à l'éradiquer mais au
moins à la combattre il faut vraiment
que nous soyons fermes sur les valeurs
qui sont celles de la france et que nous
nous battions tous et c'est l'action de
nous tous au quotidien qui permettra je
dirais de passer des messages et de
multiples hommages au colonel de
gendarmerie ont eu lieu dans les
yvelines ce graphe d'abord que vous
allez voir du street artist cette nuit
l'oeuvre a été réalisée dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi dans le centre ville de
port marly avec ce message
soyons fiers de son courage et
n'oublions jamais son sacrifice
une minute de silence a été aussi suivis
en simultané mercredi matin au
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines
et à la préfecture de versailles
le gendarme connaissait bien le
département est des yvelines après des
études au lycée militaire de saint cyr
l'école arnaud beltrame avait été
affecté au peloton de véhicules blindés
à satory entre 2002 et 2006 en 2015 il
était revenu à versailles pour intégrer
l'école européenne d'intelligence
économique
la ville a d'ailleurs décidé de donner
son nom à l'une de ses rues dans le
reste de l'actualité un rendez-vous pour
l'emploi de 12 heures au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
jeudi en piste pour l'emploi rully près
de 4000 personnes et chefs d'entreprises
organismes de formation ou demandeurs
d'emploi une première inédite dans
l'enceinte sportive et une édition
spéciale aussi pour tv 78 sur place avec
en plateau notamment erwan le gall
délégué à l'emploi et à l'insertion
professionnelle à saint quentin en
yvelines
extraits nous avons fait le constat que
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
il y a toujours des forums pour l'emploi
mais à mesure plutôt petite part par
commune il est préférable de mutualiser
et être dans une synergie très forte sur
un lieu emblématique c'est à dire que le
fait de rassembler et de se rassembler
sur un tel lieu a permis aussi de
présenter un show room avec 150
entreprises d'avoir un schiro kruth avec
2000 offres d'emploi plus de vie l'autre
sur un autre secteur d'activité d'accor
avec une plate forme d'accueil
voilà justement saint quentin en
yvelines c'est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien derrière
la défense ici seize mille entreprises
145 mille emplois le territoire regorge
d'atouts alors il regorge d'atouts nous
avons aussi un atout
particulier c'est que nous sommes à
l'aune de paris saclay donc c'est un
tout c'est un ensemble est impatient
économique très très fort très très
puissant
donc nous devons jouer ensemble et pas
chacun dans notre couronne et vous
pouvez retrouver l'ensemble de cette
interview de nos reportages émissions et
journaux et évidemment sur notre site
internet ou applications tv 78 attrape
les rythmes scolaires continuent de
faire débat mardi soir une cinquantaine
d'enseignants et représentants syndicaux
s'est rassemblée devant la mairie il
s'oppose à la demande de dérogation
formulée au ministère de l'éducation
nationale par la ville trappes souhaite
le retour à la semaine de quatre jours
en maternelle mais veut maintenir à
quatre jours et demi en élémentaire les
manifestants dénoncent un passage en
force de la mairie ils ont pris la
parole lors du conseil municipal
trente trois conseils d'école sur 36 se
sont prononcés pour un retour aux quatre
jours et cela monsieur le maire
veut nous mettre devant le fait accompli
sur une expérimentation avec la
suppression du centre du mercredi matin
pour les
pour les maternelles donc soit une perte
de 108 heures
de 108 heures à l'année les enseignants
se sont exprimés il y a eu des sondages
d'effectuer donc on peut pas dire que la
parole ne leur paye n'aura pas été donné
maintenant le résultat de ces sondages
montrent qu'une écrasante majorité et
pour le retour à quatre jours et guy
malandain le maire de la ville a répondu
à ses déclarations il a notamment
indiqué que le maintien des quatre jours
et demi en élémentaire serait bénéfique
pour les écoliers le retour à quatre
jours en maternelle répond en revanche
selon lui à une fatigue des plus petits
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
n'a toujours pas indiqué s'il l'accepté
ou non cette dérogation
l'attenté aura duré 11 ans pour l'ancien
collège bergson à montigny le bretonneux
le site fermé en 2007 vient d'entamer
une phase de déconstruction avant une
démolition totale du bâtiment dans les
prochaines semaines cent trente six
nouveaux logements et un pôle culturel
se reconstruit en lieu et place du
collège un projet structurant pour la
commune reportage est difficile
d'imaginer qu'il y a une dizaine d'année
des élèves avec ou entre ses murs ou que
des collégiens cours est ici à l'heure
de la récréation fermé en 2007 le
collège bergson et désormais un vaste
chantier depuis le mois de janvier les
ouvriers sont les nouveaux maîtres des
lieux que là nous terminons le
désamiantage et nous terminons nous
sommes en plein curage c'est à dire que
nous enlevons toutes les cloisons
intérieures et doublages l'appauvrît les
radiateurs
voilà pour qu'il nous reste qu'à la fin
que du béton une véritable mise à nu du
bâtiment donc qui précède une démolition
à partir du mois de mai c'est alors que
débutera la véritable construction d'un
projet phare pour la ville promesses de
campagne en 2014 le nouveau pôle
culturel de quatre étages l'installation
des danseurs musiciens et amateurs de
théâtre est prévue en 2020 dans des
locaux ultramodernes au coeur du
quartier de lasours de riz il est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui
dans les locaux actuels tout ce qui est
sono et autres ne correspond pas du tout
et parce que j'ai une certaine vétusté
donc là oui on aura une offre
complémentaire ou supplémentaires dans
des locaux vraiment adapté le nouveau
site verra aussi la construction de 136
logements répartis autour du centre
culturel coût net de l'opération pour la
ville 8 millions d'euros
la ville qui a lancé un concours
jusqu'au 1er juin pour trouver un
nouveau nom à l'établissement preuve
sûrement qu'une page se tourne à
montigny le bretonneux
c'est une première dans les yvelines une
station d'hydrogène a été inaugurée
mercredi matin aux loges en josas près
du siège de l'entreprise à l'origine du
projet le centre permettra de
ravitailler et des professionnels avec
du carburant nouvelle génération il sera
100% écologique et n'émettra aucun à gaz
à effet de serre les détails avec ce
reportage de michael et demi d'euros un
nouveau carburant arrive dans les
yvelines stations d'hydrogène a été
inauguré ce mercredi 28 mars aux loges
en josas cette énergie verte fabriqué à
partir de ressources renouvelables en
normandie ne produira ni gaz à effet de
serre ni particules fines
la recharge se fait en quelques minutes
à la pompe pour un prix équivalent à
l'essence c'est le même usage
un usage diesel ou essence à la
différence de la batterie ou vous devez
chargé des électrons là vous charger
directement du gaz est beaucoup plus
rapide dans un premier temps la station
sera utilisée principalement par des
bennes à ordures des taxis présents sur
le territoire et deux bus à hydrogène
sur la ligne 264 qui dessert les villes
de buc et de versailles
on commence par les premiers jeunes
parce que ça permet de développer des
logiques de flottes captives
qu'ils reviennent sur les stations dont
ça permet de charger les stations du bit
et de les rendre rentable plus
facilement mais la vision à long terme
c'est que vous avez aussi des voitures
particulières
j'ai quelques collaborateurs des états
unis qui tourne sur des voitures sur les
voitures hydrogène avec plaisir vous
avez plus de 7000 véhicules dans le
monde qui sont des véhicules
particuliers une vision à long terme qui
a séduit l'agglomération de versailles
grand parc
c'est l'enjeu du 21e siècle comment
sauver la planète et toutes les
entreprises essayent maintenant de
s'inscrire dans cette nouvelle dynamique
coût total de ce projet 1,5 million
d'euros pour être rentable la station
doit accueillir entre 50 et 60 véhicules
par jour à terme la station prévoit
également de ravitailler en carburant
des vélos à hydrogène jusqu'à dimanche
se tient la semaine de l'industrie focus
cette année sur l'industrie connectés
c'est dans ce cadre que à lundi bruno le
maire s'est rendu à maurepas accompagné
d'une quinzaine de lycéens 17 mar le
ministre de l'économie et des finances a
lancé cet événement national dans une
entreprise de la ville spécialisée dans
le design des grands noms de
l'automobile des bateaux et de
l'aviation en tout une dizaine
d'événements se déroule dans les
yvelines
dans le cadre de cette semaine de
l'industrie jusqu'à dimanche donc c'est
la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour de
l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv2 78 d'ici là restez
connectés et informés grâce à notre
application tv 78 bon week-end à tous
attention à ne pas manger trop de
chocolat aussi ce week end et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]